freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge ein tag persönlicher koch
wir starten hier in einem sehr
ungewohnten szenario wie sind nämlich in
der toskana mein heutiger gast sebastian
mein bruder ist mit mehr wir gehen
nämlich jetzt einkaufen und nicht um das
szenario summers ich habe auch eine neue
kamera gekauft deshalb entschuldige ich
mich für alle probleme die das
vielleicht mit sich bringt wir checken
jetzt die feinsten italienischen
lebensmittelgeschäfte ab
[Musik]
traumhaft möglich leute es war so geil
italienische supermärkte nehmen deutsche
supermärkte so hopps es gab so geile
sachen aber was seht ihr im laufe der
folge ist so wir mehr zum haus davon ist
jakob ihr tagesgeld und ich sage so viel
besteht im bild die küche ist
übertrieben es darauf dass ich ein
bisschen unordentlich dass wir hier mit
sechs jungs nennt gasherd dann kann ich
wieder verworfen und ich habe auch die
letzten tage damit korrekt war quasi
persönlicher koch von der truppe hat es
war sehr guten frühstück bereits ich
habe aus logistischen gründen mich
entschieden die meisten sachen nur für
sebastian zu machen natürlich es los mit
einem sandwich das seinesgleichen so das
ist ein avocado dax also aber gerade war
ja klar sein aber gerade luxair will ich
dazu gibt es pro salate nicht so im
supermarkt gekauft hat just sebastian
und das machen wir jetzt
ich habe im italienischen supermarkt
einfach zwei solcher brote geholt finde
ich sind nice geeignet eigentlich um so
ein sandwich daraus zu machen probiere
ich einfach was ist überhaupt der zählt
da das ganze aber noch ein bisschen
frech wenn ich ein bisschen mit dem ofen
aufbacken / wahr machen uns einfach geil
ich für tiere schnell die avocado ja
einfach es ist ein sehr einfaches stück
vielleicht sogar mit das einfachste
passiert hatte bestehen aus vielen
komponenten das hier ist unser ansatz
war oder ob das wort erzählt er sich so
gewünscht ich persönlich glaube ich ein
großer fan von frischkäse in dieser
konstellation aber und weil das brot wie
gesagt ein bisschen hart ist und dies
gerne ein bisschen krank hätte mache ich
jetzt einfach nach
nordrhein einfach nur für 23 zudem
sandwich sebastian sich von mir noch
exotische früchte gewünscht und ich
dachte an ananas weil die exotisch ist
dennis leute die richtig richtig gut ich
glaube dieses perfekt greift auf jeden
fall ein vielseitiges frühstück leute
und bis alles andere fertig ist stelle
ich aber auch die anderen kühlschrank
und verstreichen das ganze schnell
draußen noch mal ordentlich aufgebracht
und trend ist aber schön flach und weich
ich würde sogar navy das paket
vielleicht nur von einer seite belegen
und die andere sperren das ist die mit
dem holper essen kann
die optimalen wir das in der reihenfolge
lachs den normalmenschen will ich jetzt
aufhöre und ich für so was kommt die
ganze packung war das tut mir einfach
mit ein bisschen mit dem paul vor und
wir machen ja auch noch was kleiner soll
ja leute die das nicht denn es finden
aber ich finde in der grube stehe aber
dass manchmal ein bisschen stolz haben
ich kannte das ist eine klassische
allgemeinen maritim angehaucht ist
frühstück wartet die fast ausgedacht das
macht er schon gezeigt noch diese
vanille croissants hier so viel zum
thema gesund
[Musik]
beim frühstück geistes kann ich habe
richtig bock hunger und ich muss glaube
ich sagen korrigiere mich nicht falsch
ich glaube das ist die geilste aussicht
mit der ich jemals gefrühstückt habe ich
glaube du hast recht das wir schmecken
ananas pieces hypo salat avocado lachs
brot mit ein bisschen klein war geld das
man so ein bisschen das öl abfangen kann
vom käufer ganz wichtig leute kultur
er kommentiert euro trägt der hier alle
krieg nicht man hat den clans gesundheit
dann will ich nicht weiter stören ich
hole mir auch etwas zu essen und dann
kommen wir gleich zu bewerten wieder
hier passend zum klassischen zum
frühstück treffen sich noch so ein die
hard rock song mit creme abbas die ci
konform mit so einer vanillecreme da
drin
das ist so in italien sofort also die
italiener frühstück eigentlich voll oft
so dass sie nur so eine süßigkeit oder
sowas und kaffee oder so es und das ist
alles sehr untypisch klares gerade ich
sehe schon den kommentar kommt von dem
vater fertigen benutze ich muss auch ich
mich selbst ein bisschen überrascht mit
der crazy ist von dieser
zusammenstellung nachhinein hätte also
das war dann wirklich crazy aber es ist
natürlich zumindest gesund muss sein
eine sache die maxi gar nicht
kontrolliert und ich bin auch ganz offen
mit euch die avocado über mir persönlich
zu einer der sehr sehr gerne bisschen
bis hat in der avocado pflegen weiß aber
nicht ob ich dir dafür ein minuspunkt
also ich hab dich halt zu gebieten sie
war genauso wie ich gerne wissen
sonderwünsche immer ja okay ich glaube
ich gebe dem ganzen geht dem ganzen
nacht von 10
ich hatte im frühjahr wahrscheinlich
auch nach von single geben weil manche
sachen die wir schon gemacht hat man
einfach ein bisschen krasser insgesamt
dafür werden jetzt beim mittagessen da
anknüpfen und mittagessen wir machen ein
steak hier also knoblauch und öl soße in
dieser fahne und spaghetti hier ihr
merkt schon heute ist relativ viel
simpel ich für das aber denn richtig
gutes essen kann auch super einfach sein
kann zum beispiel beim letzten mal also
muss ich immer super viel arbeit sein
aber dann zählen die zutaten
dementsprechend habe ich hier frische
pasta geburt die eigentlich sehr
spaghetti aber sind alle linie
noble olivenöl italienischer sowieso gut
und hier von der fleischtheke ein stück
fleisch ich wollte eigentlich ein filet
holen ein bisschen komisch dass man
nudeln weg ist aber ich darf keine frage
stellen ich kann einfach nur kopf das
mache ich in diesem bretter hier wir
haben zwar draußen auch im übelsten
grill aber bis man den an hat das ist
halt so eine gemauerte um ein holz
verbrennt und auf der glut gilt also
übels geil aber viel zu kompliziert
haben wir schon mal gemacht diesen
urlaub mache hier ist mir das alles an
so die fahne heißt schon die ganze zeit
vor dass die richtig heiß ist ich habe
leider kein stativ das haben muss ich
mir ein bisschen behelfen wir müssen
jetzt allerdings noch stehen sie sollen
das ist wenn ihr wissen wollt was maxim
kaufen hat dann guckt bei den
persönlicher kaufen hier vom sonntag
vorbei direkt gesehen
dave ist hier gerade reingekommen der
film gerade eine haustür von dieser
kleinen villa in der wir hier sind
schaut euch unbedingt an wenn es euch
interessiert ist nehme ich natürlich
denkbar einfach aber ich weiß nicht ich
glaube viele kennen das sowieso als
nicht auf jeden fall eine sache die
jeder mal gemacht haben muss das wasser
fängt schon fast an zu kochen wir
brauchen aber auch gar nicht lange so
ist auch mit das schnellste essen was
man machen kann
knoblauch schneiden was man so kleine
würfel die fahne las ich übrigens auch
höchster stufe die ganze zeit waren
werden weil die muss halt einfach gas
geben
wir geben uns ein bisschen olivenöl
hierhin ein bisschen natürlich ein
bisschen viel weil das ist immerhin die
grundlage für unsere sog man muss
aufpassen dass der knoten auch nicht
braun wird wir wollen einfach nur ein
bisschen anschwitzen
das thema kommt aber es ist nicht sehr
einfach leute hier zu kochen ich gebe
einfach noch etwas mehr über das ist
übrigens wurde was auch für die anderen
jungs für die couch auch schnell ein
paar nudeln die müssen leider normales
zu essen man hier vorne hitze mal
komplett aus die pfanne ist smoking hat
wir geben
[Musik]
überhaupt bemüht
wenn das wieder ein
es ist einfach wichtig bis äußerst
wichtig galt auch schon darauf
eingegangen dass zwei bis vier wochen
klar und beitraten mehr gibt dann geht
es gleich zehn logischerweise die nudeln
hier sind auch beim abkochen und lassen
den tag legt wenn man gestorben ist
dienstlich oder ihr dann müssen wir aus
japan raus mussten leute wie angekündigt
kommt ein bisschen chili rein du sagst
du wieviel hast ja schon sehr gut sein
dass du weißt nicht was du und wir geben
jetzt eine funktion die unteren reihen
ruhig ganze wird hier aufnehmen
dafür mischt detail ist aber die wende
diese news
ich habe doch keine so großen teller ist
japan der pfanne serviert ihr habt gute
würde es lieben oder dann holen wir
jetzt mal dass speck heraus letztlich
würde sagen leute ich richtig jetzt
alles final an und dann sehen wir uns
gleich
sollte ich bin sogar auf dieses essen
mein gott dann würde ich sagen
die marseille 6 am besten
denn nun noch einmal durch ihr seht
leute wenn ihr wenn ihr so ein starker
mann werden wollt müsst ihr eine ganze
bande von essen alleine zocken danke
prof
galler knoblauch letztklassig kurze ruhe
es leute ist es zumeist und dann gleich
wieder
also muss sagen das habe ich richtig
android genau das wollte ich so richtig
schön ölig richtig schön nice billig ich
muss sagen ich glaube was ist noch lang
gemacht hätte ehrlich gesagt wird mir
ganz ehrlich und offen mit euch wäre
wenn man glaube ich normale spaghetti
genommen hätte weil die pasta finanz hat
am ende ein bisschen wenig bis die
creation sich aber ultra die sehschärfe
liza knoblauch nice angebratenes fleisch
geben ganz nachvollziehen
das schmeckt leute wir sehen uns beim
abendessen weiter geht's mit dem
abendessen und ihr fragt euch vielleicht
warum ist dieser typ wieder in seiner
eigenen küche ich sag's euch so wir
beiden war nach dieser massiven fahne
voll essen gestern abend nicht mehr in
der lage noch irgendwas zu essen da sind
wir schlafen gegangen heute morgen ins
auto gesprungen und jetzt gerade eben
vor 10 minuten aus der toskana wieder zu
hause angekommen
hast du hunger ja ja ich habe extra
jetzt sieben stunden also nichts
gegessen extrabreit es gibt damit jetzt
das beste ist leute ich habe die
feinsten italienischen zutaten
importiert aus der toskana frisch mit
eiern das war aber die ganze zeit im
auto dementsprechend gefühlt also im
kofferraum parmesan letzte habe ich
direkt und offen mit wasser aufgesetzt
ist wieder eine sehr einfache mahlzeit
nämlich hotel die alte courier mit
trüffelöl kommen soll und ob er seinen
verkäufern weil ich da natürlich noch
ein bisschen butter anschwitzen werdet
denn dass trüffel ist ja sehr dominant
im geschmack und ich dachte mir das wird
am besten begleitet von etwas wie butter
und öl wäre da zu dominant kann man auch
lange um so ich zeige euch die sehr
überschaubaren arbeitsschritte wir geben
einfach die tat elli irgendeine art
kraftvoll zu löschen
die müssen wir jede frische passte
einfach ein bisschen kochen bis sie hoch
steigen und wir geben das natürlich für
eine ganze familie
die kleinen löffel butter in die pfanne
jetzt auch digger als hätte ich im
detail nicht gut genug gegessen so was
soll das und wir geben dreieinhalb kilo
butter in die pfanne das ist wirklich
das heck gericht nummer einen solchen
kaufen diese gefühle sind frische pasta
dazu einfach selber mutter trüffel
butter ganz egal was für eine mutter
zwischen parmesan darüber wo ich sag's
euch leute
das ist ein restaurant würdiges gericht
wenn die zutaten gut sind und ihr müsst
keine zeit investieren ich bin ihr sehr
dankbar dafür bei nach diese autofahrt
hätte es nicht gebraucht aber es ist
einfach nur geil hier doch nicht länger
warten könnte ob das kommt jetzt hier in
die gruppe hinein
es sieht schon traumhaft aus die sind
den ganzen langen weg aus der toskana
gereicht wird jetzt muss man deutschem
wissen bevor sich die hellen
ziemlich genau zu sagen jetzt hier das
treffen soll das schmeckt man sich
direkt wie intensiv das ist erstmal
vorsichtig damit frisch gemahlener
pfeffer fleckig soll nicht zu viel denn
der parmesan hat natürlich auch noch
jede menge salz
ich weiß natürlich dass der real deal
wäre echt mit triple zu holen ja aber in
dem café wieder gestern waren hält dies
ja nicht geschafft hätten wie die folge
hier in köln aufgenommen hätten
[Musik]
reden wir gar nicht sagen rom gedacht
einfach zu essen das wird dir schmecken
ich bin ready auf jeden fall der das ist
dass es richtig dass shepard richtet
simpel aber dass shepard richtigkeit
mit über unser held unmenschlich hält
ich bin wie gesagt haben zwar mit der
kamera das ist ihr weiter schmecken und
wir sehen uns vielleicht für die
bewertung wohl jojoy man zucker versüßt
eine große portion 500 gramm gilt aber
ja kalorien beiseite wer ziege schmeckt
was ist ein paar richtig richtig richtig
geil finde es sehr schön ist dass
trüffel verlängert amüsant zuvor dazu
gepasst die konsistenz der übergabe
alles geiles krimis vergleichbarkeit und
ich gebe eine leute geil das ist ein
ehrenvolles ende für diese folge
persönlicher koch ich hoffe dass wir
euch nicht zu unaufwendig aber sebastian
war heutiger gast ich habe eben alle
wünsche erfüllt leute wir sehen uns
nächsten sonntag um 14 uhr wieder bei
einer neuen folge
und ich sage aber ich werde mir extra
mühe geben also schaltet ein bisschen
[Musik]